but I mean if we do continue down this
path and just make
so many things unaffordable for people
basically make families unaffordable
yeah what does that look like
I mean yeah birth rates will fall I
think there's this interesting situation
where the conservative party needs to
keep people owning homes
but also we have this massive continual
flow of wealth from ordinary families of
the rich
residential homes are the biggest chunk
of wealth in this country so how do you
keep Ordinary People owning homes when
you're simultaneously sucking their
wealth away the only way to do that is
to really increase the size of their
debt so I think what you will see is
massive increases in the ordinary debt
but I don't ordinary families so you'll
start seeing mortgages get much much
bigger so you'll start seeing that that
younger people will be able to buy
properties but by taking massive
mortgages and the government will have
to try and you know Boris Johnson spoke
about multi-generational mortgages and I
think they'll probably eventually become
a thing that you will have a mortgage
that you know you basically guarantee
that your kids will pay off for you
um so I think we'll see you'll see that
you'll see massive increases in debt
decrease in living standards you'll see
sort of the sort of slummization of
London you'll see this increasing divide
um
yeah it's just going to be really
unpleasant basically and yeah definitely
a lot of younger people will start
having fewer families
um
I imagine political parties and people
like Rupert Murdock and then what Rupert
Murdoch will be dead by then probably
but the Murdoch Empire will start use
that to stir the pot on
racial Division and fighting on
immigration because they'll they'll say
oh we need more workers because you're
not having kids so we're going to bring
more immigrants and then they're going
to sort of use that to like Drive
immigrants against people who were born
here I mean you're seeing that happen
um I think
we're reaching that point now where in
order to keep the rich getting richer
you need to start really hitting the
middle and that's difficult to justify
and I think the easiest way to justify
that historically if you look
historically is to get people to blame
immigrants and to blame foreigners and
to really drive up that sort of thing
historically you know these sort of
situations they tend to go far left or
far right you know what I mean and um
the far left doesn't seem to be winning
much ground but you look at the far
right you know
xenophobia racism you know to me they
all look to be on the rise you know and
that's um that is
you can justify falling living standards
if you say oh we're doing it to defend
you from these foreigners you know I
mean so I worry that things will
probably go go that way with increase
with increased division increase and the
media becoming more aggressive and sort
of trying to build divisions within
Society
um and in this country that will
probably take
it will have a racial element it will
have a religious element we even have a
gender element you see an age element
you see a North versus South element you
know you get people to point the finger
at one another and then nobody's
pointing the finger at Rupa Murdoch
who's just getting everybody's home you
know
housing could be so much more affordable
wages could be so much higher and we
could have so many more options in how
we live our lives some of them put a lot
of money into paying Economist and think
tanks to tell you that inequality is
important for the economy that is not
true
[Music]